[Music]
this is true that when I introduced you
I almost said please welcome sweet Beth
because that's how I know you that's
like your nickname well the teeth you
know the teeth are an issue I eat a lot
of sweets but also like you you know
just speak out like you you're the
sweetest gal I'm a sweet gal yeah yeah
yeah Bleich a gal you're sweet like a
guy I'd be fun lady yeah but you're a
handsome man thank you
I'd love to have a quick romp it's like
a huge woman just jumping over fences
and drinking propose oh yeah in like a
house dress my mom calls still calls me
PD sweetie so we do have that idea and
she made up a word Petey sweetie alig we
D I know I know I'll agree there's none
of the things that's not a word yeah
it's not she's like a shel silverstein
yeah what's where do you hail from I
think I mean are we talking about
background yeah nice your back French
cheese yes a little French maybe some
American Indian who I always had to
check Caucasian but I do kind of look
like a white t-shirt Campbell help me
who is that it's Tina from Martin I was
walking down Hollywood Boulevard yes do
[Music]
so I noticed this bum gal and she gal
who was homeless and she said hey do you
have any change and I said no and then I
and then she said but do you know who
you remind me of and I said Gina from
Martin and she goes
[Applause]
[Music]